et depuis hier tout est fait pour
rassurer montrer que tout est rentré
dans l'ordre un retour à la normalité
appuyé par la télévision russe quoique
bonjour Hélène avoloshin bonjour depuis
le début de cette crise qu'est-ce qui a
changé la télévision tout c'est-à-dire
que la communication a été complètement
verrouillée et au fur et à mesure que
les jours passaient on voyait depuis
qu'il a fait cet allocution la toute
première pour déclarer que
voilà que prigogi était un traître qu'il
fallait reprendre en main privé était
encore à ce moment-là en territoire
russe en train de marcher sur Moscou
depuis cet allocution et bien au fur et
à mesure que le bras de fer était on
peut dire gagner enfin on est à 1 mais
bon on sait pas le sujet au fur et à
mesure que ce bras de fer était en train
Poutine comprenait que voilà il a il
n'allait pas être tué dans dans la
soirée et bien petit à petit on l'a vu
de plus en plus entourée et non pas
entouré puisque personne ne se rapproche
jamais mais sur les premières images il
était tout seul hier soir on va le voir
cette image qui a été diffusée avoir
toujours évidemment jamais jamais en
direct toujours un enregistrement mais
avec ses forces de sécurité lors de
cette réunion où on a aperçu d'ailleurs
le ministre voilà vous le voyez en ce
moment l'image de la défense Serge goût
il est en train de regarder dans de
voilà de ranger les documents dans son
dans sa mallette et shoegoût on le
revoit ici regardez il est en costume
c'est la première fois de ma mémoire que
je le vois depuis le début depuis le 24
février 2022 depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine que je le vois non pas
en treillis en chef de guerre mais en
costume on va laisser l'interprétation
pour plus tard on va continuer parce que
il y avait une chose extraordinaire hier
soir à la télévision russe l'émission
hebdomadaire Moscou Kremlin Poutine qui
depuis 2018 est diffusé toutes les
semaines le dimanche soir entièrement
consacré au culte de la personnalité de
Vladimir Poutine le concept c'est que
Vladimir solov le propagandiste en chef
présente l'émission et puis son
journaliste Pavel ZAR Robin suit Poutine
dans tout ce qu'il fait pendant la
semaine et il est le seul parmi tous les
journalistes à avoir quelques minutes
pour aller lui poser des questions
l'idée c'est de montrer que voilà
Vladimir Poutine c'est quelqu'un qui est
proche du peuple proche de de 20 kill
qui est accessible journaliste etc donc
c'est la construction de cette émission
sauf que hier soir il y a eu une édition
spéciale de cette émission on était donc
lundi et
le but en fait de cette édition spéciale
c'était de montrer que c'était une
journée presque normale pour Vladimir
Poutine regardez les titres
toute la nuit le président est en lien
avec toutes les forces de sécurité le
jour des événements difficiles seul
notre équipe de tournage a eu accès au
Kremlin je m'adresse aux citoyens de la
Russie et vous verrez comment le
président a travaillé derrière les
porte-closes les jeux on peut vous
appeler à n'importe quelle heure même la
nuit si c'est important alors vous
l'avez entendu le putschavorité et
qualifié d'événements difficiles
Vladimir Poutine aurait soit disant
travailler toute la nuit et l'équipe de
tournage aurait soi-disant eu un accès
exclusif pour tourner ce travail toute
la nuit sauf que la dernière séquence
lorsque le journaliste lui tend le micro
il dit vous êtes accessible à n'importe
quelle heure du jour et de la nuit et
bien ça on en est sûr c'est une image
d'archives elle est extraite d'un autre
reportage qui a déjà été diffusé par les
chaînes de télévision russe la semaine
dernière c'était mercredi dernier un
sujet consacré à une rencontre de
Vladimir Poutine avec les diplômés des
écoles militaires mais hier soir dans
Moscou Kremlin Poutine tout était fait
pour donner l'impression que la
télévision russe était au cœur d'une
journée et d'une soirée presque
ordinaire pour Vladimir Poutine regardez
les caméraman et les photographes se
dépêchent pour installer leur caméra
quelques minutes plus tard il dit
bonjour Comme d'habitude salut les gars
on allocution a été enregistrée à 21h55
et à 22h il était visible dans tout le
pays
voilà tout est fait pour faire croire
que ça se passe presque en direct mais
on voit que c'est un montage et que les
journalistes en fait les nanes étaient
même pas dans la même pièce au même
moment que Poutine oui vous avez vu
Vladimir Poutine entrée et dire salut
les gars mais il y a ce moment-là un
plan de coupe du photographe qui est en
train de voilà de régler son appareil et
puis on voit revoie les images de
Vladimir Poutine qui est tout seul donc
c'est clairement à montage et puis c'est
allocution qui arrive au Vladimir
Poutine qualifie Prigogine donc de
traîtres vous savez la locution qu'il a
fait hier soir lorsqu'il a remercié
cette force de sécurité d'avoir accompli
leurs devoirs il a aussi ouvert cette
porte de sortie au combattant de Wagner
une fois la séquence terminée donc ils
ont diffusé la locution de Poutine le
journaliste tout de suite arrive dans le
couloir marche dans le couloir comme si
ça venait de se terminer regardez
nous deviendrons encore plus fort
voilà l'allocution a été enregistrée
pour Kina qualifier les événements de
traîtrise et de trahison à la réussite
bien sûr le travail du Kremlin est passé
en ce moment en régime d'exception nous
vous tiendrons au courant de la suite
nous avons pu constater en personne que
toute la journée de samedi Poutine se
trouvait et travailler dans le bâtiment
numéro 1 du Kremlin voilà donc le
journaliste ainsi sur le fait que cela
se passe quasiment direct qu'ils l'ont
suivi toute la journée ils disent nous
vous tiendrons au courant de la suite
des événements sauf que le reste de
l'émission et bien il est fait d'image
d'archives avec donc cette rencontre
avec les diplômés des écoles militaires
vous le voyez à l'écran donc c'était
mercredi dernier Vladimir Poutine qui va
déposer une gerbe de fleurs sur la tombe
du soldat inconnu il va serrer la main à
des vétérans ou encore inaugurer un
bateau-mouche tout ceci dans la foulée
comme si c'était finalement une un
week-end de ordinaire pour Vladimir
Poutine l'émission elle est présentée
par Vladimir soloviop le propagandiste
en chef
en Russie il s'est toujours celui qui
interview Vladimir Poutine et on lui est
connu pour ses diatrips extrêmement
violente envers l'Occident où il traite
l'Occident de Satan où il dit qu'il faut
employer l'arme nucléaire c'est un
partisan de la guerre nucléaire et bien
hier soir Vladimir solov est donc là on
sait que ça a vraiment été enregistré ce
week-end il dort debout il arrive à
peine à parler alors bon vu les
événements ça s'explique quand même
regardez comment donc cette séquence
avec les péter en vient d'être diffusé
regardez comment il réagit en plateau
après cette séquence
c'est très touchant ça Vladimir Poutine
et le maire de Moscou ont inauguré dans
la capitale russe un bateau-mouche qui
circulera toute l'année
c'est le premier transport maritime au
monde entièrement électrique
voilà un sujet sur les bateaux mouches
alors que la Russie vient de vivre
peut-être tentative de coup d'état une
rébellion armée avec une armée qui
marche sur Moscou pour destituer le
commandement militaire un montage un peu
grossier donc pour faire croire que
finalement ça me dit Vladimir Poutine
avait face non pas assez très Bellion
mais à une situation légèrement plus
tendue que d'habitude qui avait vite
réussi à se résoudre et c'est à l'image
donc de tout ce que la télévision russe
diffuse depuis le début de cette crise
sans précédent pour les tarus mais il ne
faut pas s'y tromper ces images qu'on
voit à la télévision russe et surtout
l'état de nervosité de Vladimir Poutine
lorsqu'il parle il bafouille il n'arrive
pas à formuler ces mots on l'entend pas
lorsque c'est en français mais c'est
très clair lorsque c'est en russe et
bien tout cela tout ça cela dit très
long sur ce qu'a vécu les tarrus est sur
la fébrilité du régime aujourd'hui et
merci pour ce décryptage Elena volo